[Music]
hello again and welcome to another
episode of what's up prof
good day walter hi martin
well i'm doing very well and i
hope you are doing well as well
i think
the lord is good to us right he's
amazing
so
today interesting topic again
a little bit about the spirit of
prophecy and what the bible
gave criteria for the riemann church for
yes let's have a talk about uh
disguised infidelity
martin isn't it interesting how the
philosophies of the world
impact our thinking definitely
it
i mean you cannot
even think of anything
that you be have been taught in school
that didn't affect your thinking and
where does that come from it comes from
the philosophies
so
basically
if your foundation
is built on a philosophy
then you've built it on sand right
true
it must be built on a thus
says the lord
but let's not run ahead of ourselves
will you pray for us
our heavenly father thank you once again
for bringing us together
thank you for giving us an anchor in our
life
the bible
we ask that you enlightened our minds
with the holy spirit and we also bless
this discussion in jesus name amen amen
now once again let's make it quite plain
we do not
want to do these things to be
overly critical about what people say
etc
but if it
affects people's decisions as to whether
they want to
stay within the realm of what we believe
or whether they should rather depart the
scene
it becomes very important that we say
no matter what happens
there is truth and as long as truth
prevails no matter how small the
percentage that
adheres to it
then truth has not been cast aside
no it's such a relief
when
in my previously in my life i always
would
yearn to have the complete truth
and now in the past few years been
studying the seventh adventist
doctrines and the bible together
and learning that
there is a remnant
with a prophet at the end according to
the bible
and you start studying that prophet
it was such a relief
to get this unadulterated truth
and
implement it in in my life i also found
modern that when i read the bible
and
i i read the way in which
the prophets expressed themselves and
the bible writers
and then i pick up
the spirit of prophecy volumes and i
read in those and i find
exactly the same spirit
and in my life i've had the misfortune
of reading
literally hundreds of infidel books
spiritualistic books
occult books
and that spirit is
totally different
and i was so schooled in it
that it took me quite a while to get rid
of it yeah well it took moses 40 years
yes and once once i had made the
transition
when i pick up a book and i read and i
find that spirit it i immediately become
nauseated
and i have developed an aversion to that
other spirit
and it's like you can recognize it even
in the dark
just from the way in which the words are
strung together correct
god is
god is a god of love
but he's not wishy-washy
he's straightforward and he has such
wonderful sayings and he says it in so
such a nice way but
it did so
when he rebukes the israelites for
example and he says i did this for you
and you didn't listen i did that and i
punished you with this and i punished
you with that and still you wouldn't
listen and i gave you cleanness of teeth
and you wouldn't listen
who would put it like that there's no
food in your mouth you've got cleanness
of teeth you know it's such it's so
amazing i love it that and that's why
the reason i'm also saying this is i
want to encourage people
read
the bible and the spirit of prophecy yes
because the one won't take you away from
the other they will only augment each
other
and this is this is the wall and that is
why we're going to discuss this today
yes the straight testimony will cause
the shaking this is a war as to whom
will you believe
will you believe the philosophies will
you believe those that run with the
philosophies or will you believe it thus
says the lord
that's the bottom line that's it
we're going to read a few quotes
from this particular chapter in
spiritual gifts volume 3 from page 90
i was then carried back to the creation
and was shown that the first week in
which god performed the work of creation
in six days and rested on the seventh
day
was just like every other week
the great god in his days of creation
and day of rest measured of the first
cycle as a sample for successive weeks
till the close of time
quote these are the generations of the
heavens and the earth when they were
created god gives us the productions of
his work
at the close of each literal day
each day was accounted of him a
generation
because every day he generated or
produced some new portion of his work
on the seventh day of the first week god
rested from his work and then blessed
the day of his rest and set it apart for
the use of man
the weekly cycle of seven literal days
six for labor
and the seventh for rest which has been
preserved and brought down through bible
history
originated in the great fact of the
first seven
days
that is the basis
of the entire plan for humanity that's
it
everything happened
in that one week
with literal days now if we look at this
statement
and we read the bible
and it says and it was evening and it
was morning the first day
and it was evening and it was morning
the second day
and in the first days he created the
spaces and in the
last portion of the week he filled the
spaces
and the crowning act was humanity
and once that had been completed and the
animals had been named and eve was
created then the creation was complete
and they could rest in the completed
works of god that's the basis right
now when we look at modern science
how much of it do they accept
nothing
all right now i've been at our faith and
science meetings
and i look at many of our theologians
and i see that many of our scientists
and theologians and
educated people even from the medical
world that many of them don't believe it
either
look at this now the bible in genesis
puts it just as straightforward as we've
just read in this first
paragraph
how much science does it need now
to get rid of all of this it takes a
whole
universal
science that has infiltrated every
single aspect of humanity
everything
out there has an evolutionary bias
whether you're talking in the media
whether you're talking in the scientific
fraternity or whether you're talking in
the religious fraternity everything has
an evolutionary bias medical fraternity
as well and god's people are supposed to
be
separate
and have a different tune
now if we look at the modern science for
example of what's happening in virology
everything is based on evolution in fact
the evolutionary scientists with
mutations in the viral field are the
ones that are running the modern
medical
world and according to this
it's based on
sand a foundation that is built on sand
it's a card house
and it will
collapse at some stage
so very important that it was literal
days
now
our prominent people
have such an aversion to this word
literal yeah
i could mention the names but i shall
refrain but let us say that they are our
professors at universities rectors at
universities and leading figures in the
theological field
and they have an aversion to this very
first plain statement which is not only
in the spirit of prophecy but directly
in the first words of the book of
genesis
well that is basis let's continue
reading
when god spake his law with an audible
voice from sanae
he introduced the sabbath by saying
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
he then declared
definitely definitely if you like what
shall be done on the sixth day
and what shall not be done on the
seventh he then in giving the reason for
thus observing the weak points them back
to his example
on the first seven days of time for in
six days the lord made the heaven the
earth and the sea and all that in them
is and rested on the seventh day
wherefore the lord blessed the sabbath
day and hallowed it
this reason appears beautiful and
forcible when we understand the record
of creation
to mean literal days
the first six days of each week are
given to man in which to labor because
god employed the same period of the
first week in the work of creation the
seventh day god had reserved as a day of
rest in commemoration of his rest
during the same period of time
after he had performed the work of
creation in six days
there's so much theology in this
that it is mind-boggling
righteousness by faith
is ensconced in those statements
the whole issue of finding rest in god
is ensconced in this statement
so if you do not have this basis then
you have no rest therefore you are
restless
exactly and you continue to be restless
so you have to think up and dig up stuff
to con to um substantiate what you're
trying to say yes so that you can
continually remain restless
now when i when i think about myself i
mean i was an evolutionist as everybody
at nausea knows by now
and i came across the sabbath i said to
myself this is ridiculous i can't keep
the sabbath in commemoration of six
literal days of creation
therefore
this whole sabbath doesn't make any
sense
if it applies to long ages
then when you study that through that
doesn't make any sense either because
how did the plants survive without a sun
for millennia and millennia and
millennia and how did
the marine animals and the birds appear
before the land animals
and you have a total confusion nothing
works so you must throw the baby and the
bath water
out of the window
so nothing makes sense until you
understand that there were six little
days and the sabbath is a commemoration
and that it is a week of time
we'll get to that a little bit later
okay
but the infidel
this is what we're dealing with right
correct so what's the opposite of
believing that
infidelity infidelity
now if you go to a jesuit university
what will you be taught truth or
infidelity infidelity so if you're
taught infidelity then what can you
become other than infidel right that's
it
but the infidel supposition that the
events of the first week required seven
vast indefinite periods for their
accomplishment
strikes directly at the foundation of
the sabbath of the fourth commandment
it makes indefinite and obscure
that which god has made very plain
it is the worst kind of infidelity
so martin is it possible to find the
worst kind of infidelity even in our own
ranks
unfortunately it is yes
and that's what the sad thing is and
that's why i would encourage everybody
before you swallow anything that anybody
has to say
read this bible and spirit of prophecy
and compare it if that what comes out of
the mouth
is in line with it and if they speak not
according to this word
there's no light in them okay
so that's the worst kind of infidelity
for with many who profess to believe the
record of creation
it is
infidelity in disguise
it charges god with commanding men to
observe the week of several literal days
in commemoration of seven indefinite
periods
which is unlike his dealings with
mortals and he's an impeachment of his
wisdom
it's very well put right
you actually make god an idiot
if you try and say that he created all
of this in millions of years and he says
he did it in days now why would you want
to say that
because the world has indoctrinated
everyone to believe that that is true
right
so let's continue with this chapter
infidel geologists claim that the world
is very much older than the bible record
makes it
now we come again to this issue of time
which is such a bane
and such a pain
and can be such a relief if you just
accept it
yes depending on what side of this fence
you want to stand
now you know when i started off with
this and i was an atheist
i had
all the worldly wisdom all the but
what nonsense are you talking
you know
we have thousands of years of history
egyptian chronology tells us you know
we're dealing with thousands at least 10
000 and chinese mythology goes back
even before that etc etc
and
the more you studied it
you're more you realize that that
foundation is built on sound exactly
you see they had taken the egyptian
chronology and put it in a sequential
sequence
whereas many of those kings were
actually co-regions
father and son
ruling
different areas of the same kingdom
and the more knowledge
men received eventually they got to the
point
where from 10 000 they say plus
minus
3 000
bc they don't even say
more than 3 000
plus
minus
so
everything the more you studied it the
more it comes into harmony now you know
martin
just think about this
according to
this old chronology
humanity has been around for
plus minus 2 million years
right
just in my lifetime the population of
humanity has soared from 4 billion
to 7 to 8 billion and is heading towards
nine billion
if you start with one pair
how long before you have this world's
population well if you do a little
calculation and you take the the growth
rates and you take death and disease and
everything into account then we're
dealing with a few thousand years we're
not dealing with millions of years or
even tens of thousands of years
and
there are so many examples you know
within our
uh modern history one little pair of
rabbits
ends up in australia
and ravages the place and you have
billions of rabbits they devastate them
with poisons and
almost wipe them out and within just a
decade or two they have another billion
so it doesn't take so long
so
then they come with radiometric dating
well radiometric dating is based on
suppositions
so you have a a priori assumption
for example
that when you want to date the material
there must be a time when it
was zero
it's like a stopwatch like a clock you
know you want to know how quickly
someone runs around the field you must
have a start and you must have an end
now when you don't have a clock but
you're working with isotopes
then you must have a time when there
were no daughter isotopes and that's
your zero reset
so you set your clock on that and your
assumption is
that when you have volcanic material for
example appearing that that clock is set
to zero
but it never is because if you do an
analysis it can
read up to hundreds of millions of years
so
martin if you have a stopwatch
and you're testing how quick someone
runs around the track and the stopwatch
starts at 40 seconds
then it's not going to work no it's
useless right it's pathetic okay so
there are many things like this so
infidel geologists
claim that the world is very much older
than the bible record makes it
they reject the bible record because of
those things
which are to them evidences from the
earth itself
that the world has existed tens of
thousands of years let's make that
billions
and many who profess to believe the
bible record are at a loss to account
for wonderful things which are found in
the earth
which the view that creation week was
only seven literal days and that the
world is now only about six 000 years
old
these to free themselves of difficulties
thrown in their way by infidel
geologists
adopt the view that the six days of
creation were six vast indefinite
periods
and the day of god's rest was another
indefinite period making senseless the
fourth commandment
of god's holy law
it's interesting
to link that these infidel geologists
try to get rid of the six thousand years
and they try to get rid of the sabbath
without them knowing it without them
knowing so when you are on the side and
saying that okay it's not millions but
it's ten thousands of years but this six
thousand thing can't work
then you're putting yourself on the
infidel side yes you're making a
compromise between truth and error
you are drinking a concoction with a
dose of poison in it
and you're thinking you're very smart in
the process
okay so some eagerly receive this
position for it destroys the fourth
commandment
and they feel a freedom from its claims
upon them
they have limited ideas of the size of
men animals and trees before the flood
and of the great changes which then took
place in the
earth that's a very interesting one
there's a law in
evolution
which was called the law of carol
which simply states that evolution must
proceed from small
to large
it doesn't proceed from large to small
now that's eminently logical
you don't start the evolutionary process
with an elephant and end with an amoeba
you start with the unicellular and you
end with the elephant so obviously
you're going from small to large because
if you had to assume
that the animals were huge from the
beginning then you'd have to ask whoa
how did that come about that must be a
stroke of magic right
so everything has to go from small to
large
and now you look in the fossil record
and everything in the fossil record is
much bigger than what it is now
so all the animals whether you're
talking about the wolf whether you're
talking about a sloth whether you're
talking about an elephant whether you're
talking about a rhinoceros no matter
what animal you look at whether you're
looking at the insect world
they were infinitely larger than what
they are today
that's the reversal
so
looking at it
then you have to assume
that we haven't evolved we've devolved
we've become degenerate
now that is perfectly in harmony with
the bible yes we were a perfect creation
adam was about three meters tall
and now we are shrimps
and think that we are
brilliant and advanced right
but we've degenerated
if we just take our teeth we have so
many spare teeth that we have to pull
some of them
wisdom teeth and all of those things so
they must have had much larger jaws than
we had and i'm sure all the teeth fitted
so this is a very interesting thing so
when you look at the fossil record
you find exactly the opposite to what
their theory professes
and the other thing is
if evolution is true
and somewhere in the nebulous past
life somehow happened to evolve
then surely there was a very low
diversity of life one little life form
that developed
and out of that all the diversity must
have evolved so when you go to the
fossil record you should find low
diversity in the beginning
and vast diversity at the end
but why do you find the exact opposite
huge diversity in the beginning
with a
degeneration and decline
to today that's the reverse of what you
would expect
so one of the two is lying
either the infidel geologist is lying
and the infidel evolutionist is lying
and the infidel
anybody else who accepts their testimony
is a co-partner in lying or the bible is
lying
you can choose pick and choose i'll take
my chance with the bible
bones of men and animals are found in
the earth in mountains and in valleys
showing that much larger men and beasts
once lived upon the earth
you know martin it's almost like i'm
preempting what it is saying here but
this is something that's always been
fascinating like the dinosaurs
massive creatures
or the mastodons or any one of them
or the giant sloth
we don't see those creatures today
but in some cases like in the case of
the giant sloth for example we find
their skins
still intact
but if they've been extinct for millions
and millions of years then that is an
impossibility
nevertheless we find them
and then we find fossils of
men like grauba man 2.7 meters tall
what is going on here there's something
mysterious something seriously wrong you
know what and also interesting to me is
she's mentioning them these much larger
men and the bible talks about giants
and now people run away with the word
that they use for giants nephilim
and they say this is a hybrid between
and fallen angel and human beings
that's it's impossible in the first
place and secondly
adam was a giant
absolutely
he was
over three meters he was the tallest of
them all yeah so that the race in those
days were these giant men the giants
were that were involved there in the
early times the word nephilim also means
apostate exactly
so they were all giants and you had the
descendants of those that followed the
line of adam and zeth and you had the
line that followed the line of cain
and those were the daughters
where the daughters of men came from and
eventually
the sons of god
who were
the descendants that clung to the truth
they went to the mall and they saw all
of these beautiful well-proportioned
very large ladies
and uh
with their short little mini dresses
and they saw that they were beautiful
and that's where the rot ended yeah
but of course if you prefer the catholic
approved bibles then you have this
nonsense
that angelic beings that cannot
procreate
even because some people now want to try
and put it yes but the fallen angel took
on human form no no no
this then it's not an angel that pro
procreated it was a human still yes even
there's no logic in this
whole um
thinking no logic and it's very simple
the descendants
of
god's line of people eventually
intermingled with those that had lost
faith in god and that is where the rock
set in and god you know god told his
people in the days of israel
don't intermingle with the other nations
it wasn't the question that it was
forbidden to marry someone from another
race or another people it was
not to income intermingle with those
that didn't have the same religious
conviction
because you would be drawn down and
history proves that's what happened to
solomon that's what happened to all of
them
and
ruth for example was a moabitess god
strictly forbade any union with the
moabites
but she wasn't the moabite test anymore
because she said your god will be my god
and your people will be my people and
therefore she's even in the line of
christ
so we need to
read these things properly
i was shown that very large powerful
animals existed before the flood which
do not now exist instruments of warfare
are sometimes found also petrified wood
because the bones of human beings and of
animals found in the earth are much
larger
than those of men and animals now living
or that have existed for many
generations past
some conclude that the world is older
than we have any scriptural record of
and was populated long before the record
of creation by a race of beings vastly
superior in size to men now upon the
earth
so you have all these theories of a
double creation
and there was first something and then
it was destroyed and then you have adam
and eve story and you have all of these
compromises
no there was one creation they were
giant people they were large if you take
the petrified forests if you take the
coal fields of the world these are huge
trees and things which were buried and
all of the animals which were so huge
and large
they testify of a perfect
different creation
in the sense of a superior creation
which has degenerated
over time
just take
the pre-flood generation they all
almost became 900 or more years old
immediately post flood it drops to 400
and something
by the time you get to abraham it's 180
by the time you get to moses it's 120 by
the time you get to david if it's 17 if
you're lucky it's 80.
i've been shown that without bible
history geology can prove nothing
relics found in the earth do give
evidence of a state of things differing
in many respects from the present
but the time of their existence and how
long a period these things have been in
the earth are only to be understood by
bible history and martin you cannot date
fossils
it is a misnomer
you can date the rocks around the
fossils but even then you have an
assumption which is not necessarily
valid as a starting point so dating is
basically
meaningless unless it is
of a very specific known period
just take how important this statement
is if your understanding of the age of
anything
is
transcending the six thousand year
period
you run into a problem because that's
what the bible says you come into
conflict with scripture yeah
now we've had many discussions like this
and i'm sure our viewers are
are beginning to see where we're going
to go with this
if you start messing with this 6 000
year period
then you run the risk of
infidelity that's a problem
it may be innocent to conjecture beyond
bible history if our suppositions do not
contradict the fact found in the sacred
scriptures
but when men leave the word of god in
regard to the history of creation and
seek to account for god's creative works
upon natural principles
they are upon a boundless ocean of
uncertainty
just how god accomplished the work of
creation in six literal days he has
never revealed to mortals
his creative works are just as
incomprehensible as his
existence
and then she quotes from the bible great
is the lord
and greatly to be praised and his
greatness is unsearchable
which doeth great things past finding
out yay and wonders without number which
doeth great things and unsearchable
marvelous things without number
god thundereth marvelously with his
voice great things do with ye
which we cannot comprehend
oh the depths of the riches both of the
wisdom and knowledge of god how
unsearchable are his judgments and his
ways past finding out
for who has known the mind of the lord
who has been his counselor
isn't it interesting that humanity is so
much cleverer than god
and they continue to grow even more
intelligent
so if you continue with this chapter the
word of god is given as a lamp unto our
feet and a light unto our path
those who cast his word behind them and
seek by their own blind philosophy to
trace out the wonderful mysteries of
jehovah
will stumble in darkness
so martin let's just get this straight
anything that contradicts this written
word is a philosophy that's it
a guide has been given to mortals
whereby they may trace jehovah and his
works as far
as will be for their good
inspiration in giving us the history of
the flood has explained wonderful
mysteries that geology independent of
inspiration never could
now
i was i was there
i was an evolutionist i used to go on
field trips with students and look at
the geological record
and we have a marvelous geological
record in south africa and we have the
kuru fields with all the dinosaurs and
we have all those ages and those vast
fossil fields of marine organisms the
ekka for example
and i was always fascinated how
perfectly these fossils are preserved
and how they lie in mass graves
and i was told that these were local
floods that had buried them
local floods over entire continents
that doesn't make any sense whatsoever
and i went to the petrified forests both
here in namibia and on mount hornaday in
yellowstone national park and all of
these places
and they're stream orientated
even the upright ones
so
the evidence for a universal flood is
overwhelming
and then you have the chalk layer
mountain
which is universal which means
everything was under water
but they have to
delete daily and
step around these things because they
don't have an answer that's the thing
you have to have volumes and volumes of
books to try and negate what the bible
just said is plain and simple correct
you are absolutely right
it has been the special work of satan to
lead fallen man to rebel against god's
government and he has succeeded too well
in his efforts
he has tried to obscure the law of god
which in itself is very plain
has manifested a special hate against
the fourth precept of the decalogue
because it defines the living god the
maker of heaven and earth the plainest
precepts of jehovah turned from
to receive
infidel fables
so there we have the word
infidelity again
and why is he got such a hatred for the
fourth commandment
because that's the one that says the
creator of everything
at the authority
yes he's the authority
and that's the word that bugs him
that little word authority
and he wants to set up his own authority
man will be left without excuse god has
given sufficient evidence upon which to
base faith if he wish to believe
in the last days the earth will be
almost destitute of true faith have we
reached that point yes
upon the merest pretense the word of god
will be considered
unreliable
martin what if you put so many versions
of god's word out there that nothing can
be reliable that's a
very good plan from the enemy
while human reasoning will be received
though it be in opposition to the plain
scripture facts
men will endeavor to explain from
natural causes the work of creation
which god has never revealed but human
science
cannot search out the secrets of the god
of heaven and explain the stupendous
works of creation
which were a miracle of almighty power
any sooner and it can show how god came
into existence
the only reason i know that god exists
is because
i exist that's it
right
now descartes said i think therefore i
am
making himself god
he should have said i am therefore i
think
then it would have been better for him
right
so but that's the way of jesuit thinking
they will always twist decath of course
was jesuit and jesuit trained
and
they and their infidel
theology and philosophy
are at the root of much of this evil in
the world and they are at the root of
higher criticism so that's why you sit
with all this nonsense of
oh but we can't take the bible literally
we can't do this we can't do that
where we can't go back to a thus saith
the lord
correct so if there is if there is no
foundation
then how can you build a proper building
i mean
if you want to prove to the world
evolution does not exist
why not
why aren't you allowed to use the bible
all right what have we established so
far because we're not going to just talk
about evolution creation here right
we have established that there is a
certain foundation
and if you take this word martin
and you pick it up
and you open it up
at the book of genesis
and you start with those words
in the beginning god created the heavens
and the earth
that's a stupendous way to start
a revelation from god right exactly
you come from somewhere
and god says he did it
the earth was without form and void and
darkness was upon the face of the deep
and the spirit of god moved upon the
face of the waters and god said
and then it goes god did this god said
god did god said god did god said god
did
and he's talking about elohim a plural
therefore
the godhead
was
in
this creation process
if we continue our reading here the
secret things belong unto the lord our
god
but those things which are revealed
belong unto us and to our children
forever
men professing to be ministers of god
raise their voices against the
investigation of prophecy and tell the
people
that the prophecies especially of daniel
and john are obscure
and that we cannot understand them so
now martin we're moving from the
purely physical to the spiritual yeah
now if the creation account is obscure
and needs to be redefined
maybe we must redefine the prophecies
that's what happens
what is that what they're doing exactly
and then you go into infidelity now
who's doing this
men who are supposed to be
religious teachers within
god's people right
okay
but some of the very men who oppose the
investigation of prophecy because it is
obscure
eagerly receive the supposition of
geologists which dispute the mosaic
record
but if god's revealed will is so
difficult to be understood certainly men
should not rest their faith upon mere
suppositions in regard to that
which he has not revealed
god's ways are not as our ways neither
are his thoughts as our thoughts
all right so this doesn't just stay with
the physical and with geologists but
that's where the rut starts exactly
human science can never account for his
wondrous works god so ordained that men
beasts and trees many times larger than
those now upon the earth and other
things
should be buried in the earth at the
time of the flood and there be preserved
to evidence to man
that the inhabitants of the old world
perished by a flood
god designed that the discovery of these
things in the earth should establish the
faith of men
in inspired history
now isn't it interesting
that throughout the ages godly people
believed that what you found in the
rocks was evidence of a flood
yes
that's how it was supposed to be and
then came darwin
and it's interesting he sent out his
first draft
in 1844
so this is particularly for the last
generation
to confuse them utterly
now the reformers
they believed in the creation and they
believed in the flood
but our modern scientists don't and many
of our theologians don't and many of our
religious leaders don't
but men with their vain reasoning make a
wrong use of these things which god
designed should lead them to exalt him
they fall into the same arrows that the
people before the flood those things
which god gave them as a benefit they
turned into a curse
by making a wrong use of them
and when the foundations of the earth
were laid then was also laid the
foundation of the sabbath so
you cannot divorce the sabbath from the
creation no and vice versa so when you
destroy creation in six little days you
go to evolution and
millions of years or even thousands of
years
you destroy the sabbath someone do you
keep the seventh day as the sabbath yes
but you're keeping a jewish sabbath
no i'm keeping a godly sabbath that was
instituted in genesis already long
before there was a jew right
in the simple
or
if you look at it just this one little
phrase jewish sabbath oh and the papacy
loves that statement they obviously
never read genesis
they were probably trained at jesuit
universities right
so this tells us that immediately
they want to introduce infidel theology
and counter what it says in the plainest
teachings of the bible
all right now this is very interesting i
was shown
that if the truth sabbath had been kept
they would never have been an infidel or
an atheist the observance of the sabbath
would have preserved the world from
idolatry
why martin
because they would have believed god
because the sabbath is rooted
in the word of god and it's rooted in
the creation week
and if you keep the sabbath
what you are basically doing is
acknowledging to the entire universe
that you believe god rather than
infidels
you know what you can't cannot put it
better that you just put it that's 100
all it is to it
you acknowledge god as a supreme
authority that's why you've spent
your time
on the day that he
is there to spend with you okay so if
you keep the sabbath will the geologist
become irritated with you oh yes
will those that believe the geologist
become irritated with you yes
all right and if there are people within
the church's ranks that believe the
geologist over the word of god will they
become irritated with you yes
so this looks like a
a issue of conflict
100 what it is and then that is what's
creating this
disguised infidelity
you sometimes don't even know that
you're you're busy with your infidelity
yes because you've swallowed some toxin
which has
mutated into a monster in your mind
now martin this creation week
which serves as a model for everything
that comes thereafter
the early church believed
that it also serves as a model for the
entire plan of salvation stretching over
6 000 years with the millennium
of the seventh day
representing the thousand years of rest
and that was called the cosmic week
now our modern theologians
seem to have a tremendous aversion to
the cosmic week right
but that's what the early church fathers
believed and we did a whole study on
that in number nine already
but for the sake of completeness
let's just take this thinking a little
bit further yeah and just to put it out
there bear with us we we're heading
somewhere with this yes
yes
all right so let's have a look at some
of the pioneers
of the advent movement
you had wagoner
from eden to eden
and he quotes revelation 21 4 and 5 eden
is then fully restored here the river of
water of life flows out from mount zion
here adam regains the tree of life
planted beside the river
which parts into separate heads as in
the beginning here again is paradise the
garden which the lord himself planted 7
000 years before
martin is that an interesting statement
so he's taking the whole
yeah creation week
and changing it into a cosmic week
so the whole plan the six days labor
plus
the seventh day millennium of rest
seven thousand years
let's have a look what thomas preble had
to say about the two adams before the
first adam had the conflict with satan
in which he fell the seventh day of
sabbath had passed
so with the second adam before the last
and final conflict with satan and his
hosts
in which eternal victory will be gained
for the son of god and his people the
sabbath or 7
000 years will be
passed
did they believe in the cosmic week
well actually if you start you really
study this you cannot do any other did
alan white believe it for sure did god
show it
we've read previously how important it
is to put your perspective
into this
6000 in
prohibiting you from getting becoming
part of the infidels and we read the
statement from her
grandson
where he plainly stated that she was
shown
that this controversy would rage for 6
000 years and then there would be a
millennium right
let's look at what hymes had to say
signs of the times and expositor of
prophecy
this was written in 1843
if then jesus christ that does his work
in six days and rests from all his
labors on the seventh
when when may we expect the great event
to take place i answer if a thousand
years is one day with the lord as i
think i have proved then six thousand
years from the first creation the new
one must be formed and moreover if
christ worked after the example of his
father and rested as god rested from his
labors
then the seven thousand years would be a
sabbath of rest for christ and his
people
so they all believed in this concept
but now if you deny the six thousand
years
so if you want to accept the septuagint
as your standard and throw out
what the reformers use namely the
masoretic text
you are at loggerheads not only with the
bible
you're in logarithms not only with the
spirit of prophecy
you're at loga it's with the early
church fathers and you're at loggerheads
with the pioneers of the advent movement
right yeah
clock
advent review and errol 1866 the bible
answers every query and solves every
doubt
in this blessed book the lover of
history finds full information of past
and future events
beginning with the first eden and
reaching over a period of seven thousand
years to the second eden in the earth
made new
did he believe the seven thousand year
period they were so grounded in this
that i think
this shows how grounded they were in
their bible now if these people live
today
and our theologians and our biblical
research institutes were to engage them
do you think there would be some
fireworks
definitely
they wouldn't be on the same page right
okay
josiah lich the first report of the
general conference of christians
expecting the advent of the lord jesus
christ interesting title right
it has been an almost universal opinion
of the church both jewish and christian
that the sabbath prefigures a glorious
state of rest for the church during the
seven
thousand years of the world
the principal argument in favor of this
are briefly as follows
god made the world in six days rested on
the seventh
and constituted the sabbath as a type of
futurist
so we may expect that after the troubles
and commotions of six thousand years
there will be a rest of a thousand years
from all these sorrows
isn't it interesting that he also
acknowledges here that
basically the universal opinion of
church christian and jewish
had the same idea now this is very
interesting
so this is what the pioneers believed
right
now
if they were confronted with a 10 000
year argument
as we have in many many cases
uh would they accept this
no
no so what did they base it on were they
influenced by the margin of the king
james version all of them
they couldn't have been including
the spirit of prophecy was that
influenced by the margin of the king
james version no
no then why do our theologians say that
it was
because they tried to get out of
this conflict okay so on whose side are
they now compromising
unfortunately not on a good side because
what is the little word that she used
there on the side of the
infidelity
we come up against this problem of
infidelity all the time
once you start questioning this
then can't you start questioning the
other things as well didn't you say that
then you will start criticizing
daniel and you'll start criticizing
revelation
yes you might
consider
daniel revelation or even the bible not
sufficient to substantiate historical
events
all right so
the very first story
once you start
manipulating that
then you have to manipulate all the
other chapters which refer to it
once you start manipulating that you
have to manipulate what jesus referred
to when he said
and the flood came and took them all
away because that's not scientifically
uh tenable right yes
then you start
working on the books of daniel in
revelation now these pioneers were they
rooted in the creation account
definitely
were they rooted therefore in the
sabbath yes
were they therefore rooted in the
cosmic weak
absolutely all right now none of our
top theologians in the world and some of
our supposed overseers
who would want to believe this
in fact they would ridicule it
now if i chose to believe it
would i be an infidel
no but according to them yes according
to them would it become necessary to
write articles in in little magazines
about it yes denigrating this viewpoint
and
you must remember you'll have to get rid
of the spirit of prophecy you have to
get rid of that prophet if because the
prophets in line with us all right so
this is a very serious issue
and the bottom line is without trying to
be too vociferous about this issue is
who do we believe
do we believe the plain statements in
the word of god
which are corroborated by equally plain
statements in the spirit of prophecy or
do we believe
our theologians and our
scientists out there that have come to
the point of compromise with infidelity
so what can we say to them what can i
say to them because there are now two
viewpoints
and never the twin shall meet
so
all i can say is get over it
try and get over it because you will not
twist my mind back into believing what i
believed when i was an infidel atheist
when he said
if you want to believe in those gods and
that those nonsense they put there do it
but if you want to follow the god of the
bible you have to start believing what
he says all right so let's see where
this leads now this was a while ago
already in 2021
prominent professor from llu
and martin
these professors are very prominent
theologians
in our ranks
and the interesting thing is they become
so prominent that they become deans so
their their voice is very uh
important in terms of what they are
stating right and it said that they're
teachers
there's other people that are being
taught leaders that are being taught by
these people
yes
so dr john pauline is a professor at the
loma linda university school of religion
at a recent church sponsored symposium
about the end time prophetic events dr
pauline said that sunday laws are not
coming
the great controversy is outdated
there are other options for the mark of
the beast and ellen white was not an end
time prophet
the biblical evidence does not speak of
sunday as such but it speaks about the
counterfeit of the sabbath being
critical to the mark of the beast at the
end of time
so within exegesis of the biblical text
you do have options for understanding
what the mark of the beast will actually
turn out to be
we should be careful not to assume that
the end time will be identical to the
great controversy in every detail
just to make clear this great
controversy is the book the great
controversy written by alan white
correct so this is a direct
contradiction of the spirit of prophecy
now do you see
the leadership climbing onto the
bandwagon condemning these people
no no but if somebody says i believe the
great controversy in every detail and i
believe what it says about catholicism
and i believe what the reformers
believed on the very same issue
then they will make a big human cry
about it right so whose side are they on
infidelity or the bible in the spirit of
prophecy by own choosing
infidelity
considering both the bible and world
history were ellen white alive today
there is at least a chance
that her depiction of the end time would
be different than it was in the 1880s
i thought i am the lord i change not
ellen white's style of prophecy is
classical rather than apocalyptic
martin
this is playing with words this is
semantics
to make of none effect that which is
very plain is that not one of the last
means that satan will bring about the
shaking
absolutely
and finally as a classical prophet ellen
white's predictions should be understood
as conditional
as circumstances change the fulfillment
of revelation could take other forms
than the ones that seemed so clear in
so this man is casting serious doubt
upon the writings of ellen g white and
even the bible because he says the mark
of the beast are also totally different
from what we believed it to be yes
we're just reading this in an article
from the advent messenger
and some people will say well maybe
they're exaggerating right these are his
own words these are his own words yes
but i have had personal experience with
a man i've sat face to face with this
man
and he told me
in no uncertain terms
that
i was not to preach about the papacy
that it was the antichrist
although the spirit of prophecy says
expose the wickedness of the man of sin
he also told me many other things he
told me that people that come into the
church through ministries like ours
that
believe
the things that stand in the bible and
the spirit of prophecy are not welcome
in the church but it seems that people
with his ideas are not only welcome but
placed on a pedestal
is there something seriously wrong in
israel definitely i think it's time to
re-read ezekiel 8 as we've said in the
previous
episodes and so when our leading
organizations start writing articles
against those who preach the bible and
the spirit of prophecy and accommodate
individuals like this within the church
without a peep
isn't there something seriously wrong
all the way into those echelons as well
so let's put it on the table i'm not
condemning
anyone
but it is a question of who do we
believe
and if we are
seventh that day adventists at all
then we must be
rooted in what made this church what it
is
and who laid the groundwork for what we
believe
who laid the foundation now
if the foundation is wrong the building
cannot stand wasn't it the pioneers yes
and wasn't when they couldn't go any
further wasn't it corroborated and
substantiated by the spirit of prophecy
correct and now who are these people to
tear down
those foundations because if they tear
at the foundations they are tearing at
the very structure of the building and
they are add logger heads with the bible
yes they are not
in harmony with the bible the spirit of
prophecy the pioneers neither are they
in harmony with the reformers
in as far as the
the reform
reformers had light
on the issues
all right so according to
these learned gentlemen who have drunken
from the wells of infidelity
there is no sunday movement the great
controversy is wrong the papacy has
nothing to do with it there will be no
image to the beast and there will be no
implementation of the mark of the beast
you know what he said
okay
here is an article from desert news
could sabbath close your laws make a
comeback
pandemic related stress and a widespread
desire for more time to rest
are amongst the factors fueling the
great resignation
they also help explain why some
political commentators and legal
scholars
spent the weekend debating the sabbath
who martin
political commentators and legal
scholars
the conversation began with a tweet from
adrian vermill a law professor at
harvard university
he highlighted the reinstatement of
sabbath laws as one of several policy
goals that unites post liberals
a group of conservatives who say they're
focused on promoting the common good
where have you heard that word the
common good
the papacy and jesuits love that word so
it's a jesuit phrase so are we dealing
with
catholicism and it's thinking
and the legal world of the world okay
blue laws associated with the christian
sabbath helps explain why part of the
debate surrounding vermill's tweet
centered on religious discrimination
legal experts pointed out that forced
closures on sunday
disproportionately harm some people of
faith including jews who observed the
sabbath
from sundown on friday to sundown on
saturday
in may 1961 the supreme court ruled 821
that maryland's sabbath laws didn't
violate the first amendment
the justices
acknowledged that the restrictions had
their root in christian practice
but said they served important secular
purposes including the promotion of
public health
is reported
now martin that's interesting
[Music]
so we are dealing with a conflict
between two sabbaths that's it the
biblical one
and
this
christian one that child of the papacy
let's call it by its real name
and the mark of the beast
is sunday observance
because rome has identified it as such
it is a mark the fact that we have
transferred the solemnity of the
biblical sabbath to the first day of the
week is a mark of our ecclesiastical
authority
the church is above the bible that is so
arrogant
but it comes straight from the horse's
mouth catholicism
and here we have a debate taking place
about whether
sunday could be enforced in the place
of the sabbath day
yes and according to the court
it is legal
ah martin but is it lawful
not according to the bible
because if you take the instance of
nebuchadnezzar
even though it was
for implementing a law
for god
that's not how god works correct so when
nebuchadnezzar
accepted
that the god of daniel
was the true god he made a law that
nobody may worship anyone else than this
true god
and he was overstepping his bounds
because god never forces the conscience
so whether you're doing it on the side
of the right or whether you're doing it
on the side of the wrong you may not
force the conscience
so here's another article and this one
from christianity today which is a very
prominent mouthpiece
from february 4th 2022
amazon primes a sunday work dilemma
so amazon is this company that is using
every day of the week to distribute its
wares
or deliver them
with two delivery drivers suing over
schedules sabbatarian christians find
their observance increasingly counter
cultural
in a 24 7 economy now this is very
confusing
because when they talk about sabbatarian
christians they're talking about sunday
yeah they're not talking about the
seventh day they're talking about the
first day they'll name them by name the
either jews or seventh-day adventists if
they're talking about the other
christians have lamented the shift away
from business
since observing sunday sabbath for
decades
in christianity today's early days
evangelical leaders complained about the
uptick in open on sunday
signs in grocery stores theaters and
other businesses
too largely the sabbath day has been
reduced from a holy day of spiritual
replenishment instruction and correction
to a mere holiday for pleasure seeking
or to just another day of merchandising
charles w collar president emeritus of
northern baptist theological seminary
wrote in 1963
two years after the u.s supreme court
ruled that blue laws restricting sunday
commerce were constitutional there we
have it again
so they're debating whether to bring
these laws back right
christ made allowance within the spirit
of the law for works of mercy and of
necessity and for taking care of the
occasional ox and the dish collar said
but the moral responsibility
of unnecessary sabbath violation is not
to be lightly regarded immeasurably
greater is the moral responsibility
of coaxing others away from sabbath
observance to the moth of trade
still more serious is the policy of
denying the employees the possibility of
serving the sabbath so
they're raising their voices
but they've got their sabbath confused
it's not rooted in the word of god it's
rooted in a foul
foundation which is situated at the
vatican and they want to use secular
power to enforce this
yes
here's another article from religion
unplugged
and this one comes from february the
11th 2022
not just nostalgia
some pandemic weary souls want to make
sunday a day of rest again
some of us are old enough to remember
when most businesses not just
chick-fil-a
closed on sundays it seems quaint now
but i did an associated press story in
2003 on family christian stores
then the nation's largest christian
retail chain
deciding to open on sundays
but in 2016 i was surprised during the
reporting trip to north dakota when i
found an empty parking lot at the
bismarck walmart
and then at super target
while looking to buy a few snacks and
supplies before sunday morning church
i learned that for more than a century
the state had required most retailers to
close from midnight to noon on sundays
north dakota finally became the last
state to lift that ban in 2019
i bring up the subject not just for
nostalgia
but because the day of rest or lack of
it is drawing renewed consideration
nationally
martin are they beginning to debate
the sunday issue
this is brewing but john pauline said
it's not going to happen it's not part
of the book of revelation and ellen
white is outdated
now on here's another article
and this one comes from february the
17th 2022
build blue laws back
now we're using the slogan built back
better right
scripture tells us that god created
humans on the sixth day and after that
arduous effort god himself rested on the
seventh day
and god tells us that humans need to
rest on the seventh day the sabbath too
for the first couple of hundred years
that christians lived in north american
continent they kept observing the
sabbath as they had done
in the old country
the sabbath was ordained by
ecclesiastical authorities and
eventually enforced by secular
governments in america through a series
of statutes that came to be known as
blue laws now is quite right here it was
ordained by ecclesiastical authorities
yes the sabbath that they talking about
is that's exactly how it came about but
it was not the end of god no because if
they're talking about the real sabbath
and it's interesting i'll come back to
that point now but it's interesting that
they continue to say on the seventh day
but sunday is not the seventh day they
are totally confused so
then they bring it in
that
god said
rest on that day
but they say here that ecclesiastical
authorities ordained it so all earth
confused theologians they don't believe
any of these things should join these
and they can at least all be equally
confused right
what was life on the sabbath like under
blue laws well it meant that sundays
were quieter
set apart from the other six days of the
week
proponents of ending blue laws in past
decades argued that the sunday sabbath
could be a movable feast
and that it could be observed on any day
of the week but that missed the point
which was that to benefit one and all
and to be predictable for planning
purposes everything had to halt on a
sunday
of course another benefit was that
church attendance would increase
the benefits of blue laws ultimately
outweigh any temporary or minor
downsides
and politicians may find that
campaigning to establish a truly restful
and refreshing weekend
will be a hit at the polls
this fall what
is this becoming a political issue i
think it is definitely becoming
political
and the conservative right
will
definitely be looking at this well
they'd love to climb onto this bandwagon
all right
so now let's look how far we are going
here comes an article from earthbeat
also from february 17 2022
as built back better stalls faith
leaders
call biden
senate to moment for courage on climate
that's very interesting let's read
nearly 100 faith leaders have called on
president joe biden and senate majority
leader chuck schumer
to not abandon democrats sprawling built
back better agenda
and it's hundreds of billions of dollars
to combat climate change
saying this is a moment for courage
as the bill has stalled and fallen
behind other legislative priorities
we cannot delay in acting the buildback
better act this vital legislation
will protect our climate and put our
nation on a path of climate justice
environmental justice and inter
generational
justice
martin this is interesting
if you remember quite a while back we
did that episode on what that
buzzwords climate justice environmental
justice and all of this
it goes back to sunday
sunday legislation a coalition of 86
faith leaders of national state and
local faith-based organizations and
congregations
wrote in a letter february 14 addressed
to biden schumer and the full u.s senate
we share a moral call
to care for our common home
god's creation and to love our neighbors
both here and around the world the faith
leaders said
now modern if these are the buzz words
that come straight out of loda to see
and it couples it back to god's creation
does the data see couple it to sunday
yes
directly directly now here you have
faith leaders 100 faith leaders
coupling it directly with the creation
they don't speak about sabbath in
particular
but they say we share a moral call to
care for our common home
god's creation and to love our
neighbours both here and around the
world
and la dota c made it quite plain that
sunday was for our common
good and for love your neighbor and for
our common home and they had that week
of prayer for the sabbath
that linked to climate change so we've
had faith leaders
appealing directly to biden to build
back better and to put creation week
back into the picture that means putting
lauda to sea
into
operation we've had faith leaders from
the evangelical world having a week of
prayer for the introduction of the
sabbath
we've had articles that we've just read
where they argue for the reinstating of
blue laws are our theologians fast
asleep or are they drinking from the
wells of infidelity if they are fast
asleep we are encouraging them to please
wake up
and if they are drinking from that cup
of babylonian wine please refrain from
it okay i'm wondering martin whether
they're sticking to wine or whether
they've put moonshine in there to have
something stronger in order to be able
to come up with some of these statements
let's wrap this up martin with a
statement from the spirit of prophecy
from the book great controversy
which our
friend the theologian says is outdated
and needs to be redefined
the dignitaries of church and state
will unite to bribe persuade or compel
all classes to honor the sunday
the lack of divine authority will be
supplied by oppressive enactments martin
have they been practicing this over the
last two years indefinitely and that's
also included in blue laws
political corruption is destroying love
of justice
and regard for truth and even in free
america
rulers and legislators in order to
secure public favor
will yield to the popular demand for a
law enforcing sunday observance martin
is there a popular demand definitely
you've got faith leaders even
and the populace and are they praying
for the implementation thereof
liberty of conscience which has cost so
great a sacrifice will no longer be
respected well they've practiced that
now for you so maybe they've got it
right now
in the soon coming conflict
we shall see exemplified the prophet's
words
the dragon was wrath with the woman and
went to make war with the remnant of her
seed which keep the commandments of god
and have the testimony of jesus christ
martin
they have the testimony unfortunately
not all seem to believe the testimony
but the bible says to the law and
the testimony if they speak not
according to this word there is no light
in them
so my appeal is to those who want to
believe what god said
then start from the beginning
look at the book of genesis
look at the plan of salvation
look at the roots for the sabbath day
look at the war against the sabbath day
daniel in revelation he will change he
will think
to change times and laws he has done
precisely this he calls it the mark of
his
ecclesiastical authority he's got the
faith leaders clamoring for it for the
reinstating of the blue laws
and our people are saying the time is
not yet
martin
when are we going to wake
up we have to do it right now
because there's a loud cry to be given
to get people out of babylon and let's
pray for
these theologians
and for these leading figures that deny
the very basics of the advent faith
and let's pray that they wake up and
embrace the truth before it is too late
and that applies to every single one of
us
who do we believe
do we believe that thus says the lord or
do we believe the infidels
of the scientific world or the infidels
that have become intoxicated with the
wine
that is being passed around not only
by the church of rome but by all who
have imbibed in that particular drink
may god spare us because he says
we have to come out of her
lest we receive her plagues let's pray
heavenly father
this war has been raging from the
beginning it starts with the very first
sentence in the bible
in the beginning god
where the devil says no there were many
many creations and none of these things
described in the bible actually took
place
and twists
and distorts
everything else until finally the
seventh day becomes the first day
how did that happen lord
unless there was an infidel at work
help us to expose the wickedness of the
man of sin and to rely on the thus says
the word that we may stand in that great
day is my prayer in jesus name amen
[Music]
you